russia has invaded ukraine
vladimir putin has declared a special
military operation
saying he aims to denazify ukraine and
protect russia
and he has all but threatened nuclear
escalation against the west if it tries
to interfere
the economist correspondent richard
ensor is in the ukrainian capital kiev
overnight everything's changed you know
we went to bed
ukraine was a country with a with one
kind of future and we've woken up to a
completely different reality it really
is a new beginning um for ukraine for
europe and for the world
[Music]
people have been hearing that in two
days time in two weeks time in the
coming days russia will invade and like
a boy who cries wolf these reports of
sometimes
in you know
instilled in ukrainians a bit of
hardened skepticism so when there were
reports last night that yet again a
russian invasion may be imminent some
people took them completely seriously
and stayed up all night checking the
news preparing their bags and other
people went straight to bed and got a
really big shock when they woke up i
woke up early this morning and i heard
immediately through my window these very
loud sirens which suggest that in kiev
in the capital of ukraine there was
about to be an air raid so of course i
grabbed my bag and i run down to the
street and you could see that on the
streets the moot was an immediate shift
from what it had been the day before
people were very grim we heard a police
car coming by and they told us that we
needed to run to the nearest metro
station and we didn't know if this was
an impending missile raid or just
general advice it was very hard to know
so of course we grabbed our bag and we
started to run and underneath in the
metro you saw
families huddling people not knowing
what was going on checking their phones
babies in prams people with suitcases
and plastic bags full of belongings
sitting around waiting to know what to
do and incredibly at the same time
you saw people going past getting on the
metro going to work like it's like it's
a completely normal day
i've never seen anything like it before
but you also had people starting to
stock up on supplies probably to stay in
kiev for a very long time in case things
become a bit more chaotic people filling
up their tanks of gas so that they can
leave people buying medication from
pharmacies and this is a city that is
suddenly on a war footing people are
either running away to leave i can tell
you that i saw the road out west leaving
the city towards lev and the polish
border and from the very crack of dawn
that that has been backed up for hours
and kilometers and it's going to be very
hard for people to leave in that way
airspace is being closed
it's
for people who want to leave it's very
tough but of course a lot of people want
to stay because they love ukraine it's
their home
and they think it's worth fighting for a
lot of people are going to be picking up
guns the president has said that anyone
who wants a gun to defend their country
can get one in kiev a sense of order
prevails right now there are no
vigilantes on the streets there are
armed service members people from the
national guard on the streets a lot of
them are checking into military bases
today to get ready for deployment
ukraine is prepared for war because
ukraine for eight years has been at war
it has felt to ukrainians like they have
been fighting a war for eight years are
they prepared for the kind of war that's
about to break out
on a different scale against a different
kind of enemy with different kinds of
motives
that's a tremendous question and we're
going to see whether they are in the
days that unfold but certainly
the the morale and the the sense of
really there being something to fight
for is
pervasive and very strongly felt among
ordinary ukrainians right now the
western response is still unfolding um
this is going to be something that takes
several hours and days and weeks
um we're probably expecting very large
package of sanctions to be announced
from the west ukrainians want to feel
like they don't have to fight this
battle alone and
they want to see a very strong response
from the the european union from the
united states from the rest of the west
in terms of sanctions against this
russian regime that was already a
horrible place but is now
exporting chaos well beyond its borders
and towards europe
um they want to receive additional help
in terms of military aid they would love
that to keep flowing and they want to
feel like they live in a world where
these kinds of acts perpetrated against
them
are not committed with impunity they
want that they want to feel like there
is a sense of justice in the world and
that vladimir putin and his regime is
going to get what's coming to it the sad
truth of this is if you look at where
the russian military is right now
if you look at where the russian
military is going and you look at
ukrainian citizens and where they live
and who they live next to all of that
adds up to a massive refugee crisis
in poland in the rest of the eu for the
wider world
you are already seeing people trying to
get to the borders of moldova
poland trying to get through
it's not entirely clear how those
countries are going to manage with that
initial influx once they once it really
gets going whether they keep the
you know this door to safety open or
whether they slam it shut
um that debate is coming to europe right
now ukraine is a country that
considers itself european they have
europe they have eu visa-free travel
they can hop on a plane and take a
coffee in any european city they like to
under normal circumstances but these are
not normal circumstances
and the question of how to manage that
is going to be one of the
the dominant topics of discussion in the
weeks to come
for those out there asking how this is
going to end it's a great question
because all of the answers are so
unthinkable that you don't want to speak
them into existence we've we're talking
about a massive refugee crisis thousands
upon thousands of of
dead civilians and soldiers
cities
being rendered unrecognizable
in a matter of days and weeks
if this war is not called off somehow
and if the the russian
plans for regime change in kiev come to
pass
with such a strong military force and
such superior air power for that for
that kind of war
i mean how that ends
when with the ukrainian willingness to
fight it adds up to a long bloody
protracted battle
with a death toll that europe thought it
would never need to see again
if you'd like to know more about the
unfolding war in ukraine please click on
the link it will take you to our hub
with all the latest news developments
information and analysis thanks for
watching and don't forget to subscribe